yo wassup everybody it is prestigio man
luigi here with another Borderlands the
pre-sequel legendary guide today we're
looking at the bonus package the bonus
package is a legendary grenade mod
manufactured by eight org it is
explosive because it is made by torque
and so it really makes explosives
it is a it's read text reads two times
more awesome bonus extreme and it spawns
ten child grenades I think that can vary
from nine to ten but I believe it is
always one of those two high numbers
what makes this a legendary and better
than the rest is that it spawns ten
child grenades twice that's why there's
the two times so you can see it does
fourteen thousand damage times ten well
times that by two onto that because it
it'll it originally blow up and then
it'll spawn into ten small grenades and
those smaller grenades will blow up and
each spawn into ten so actually sorry
not times two times 100 that'd be 14,000
times ten times ten so it'd be times 100
and all this is a really good grenade
mod for taking out large groups of
enemies doing a lot of Splash Damage
over a large area
however being said that it can also has
it also has a large possibility to
injure yourself because it has such a
huge burst radius you can see that the
blast radius for the normal grenade is
489 but couple that with ten grenades
and then another 10 for every single one
of those grenades exploding having that
498 basically 500 blast radius around
every single one so it's a lot of blast
radius it's really easy to doubt
yourself even in one of the clips I'm
gonna show you the end of the video I
doubt myself because I got too close to
there one of the explosions but I think
it is one of my one of the grenade mods
that I liked the most it can do a lot of
good damage because there are so many
powerful grenades exploding doing tons
of explosive damage good for kindling
just a lot of groups of foot soldiers
and doing some good damage to large
bosses like especially rajaiah this
would be a good grenade on him since
he's a huge creature so a lot of the
grenades will hit him although some
smaller bosses like say the
bosun or even Felicity is kind of big
but even Felicity if you throw this at
them only a few of the grenades will hit
and all the a lot of the other grenades
will just spawn around them and not hit
them so I'm gonna be showing you how to
get this you can always get it from a
vending machine or grott I'm pretty sure
you can grind it actually no I don't
know if you can grind it I don't know if
you can grant legendary grenade bombs
you should be able to in pretty sure you
can though so I'm gonna be showing you
how to get it and kind of some gameplay
of it so hope you enjoyed all right so
to get this grenade now you're gonna
want to head to the Titan industrial
Felicity facility sorry and you're gonna
want to get there find all your enemies
and kill torques that's that's how to
get this grenade bomb is you just kill
lots and lots of torques now this area
is the I believe the highest amount of
torques of the entire game spawn in the
Titan production facility so you just
want to get here and just go around and
just shoot a bunch of torque since the
torques have a lot higher spawn chance
of drop chance of this grenade mob than
any other mob in the game and yeah
that's about it you don't want to just
kill budget orcs that's how the very my
very first playthrough of this game
I felt like whenever like three hours in
or whenever I got to this part of in
campaign I got this grenade mod from the
torques and going again I think actually
it was in a different area but if I kill
the torque and I got the grenade mod so
I do not get the grenade mod here but I
have two other instances of getting the
grenade mod during normal play
I was not farming the torx so if you
form the torque I'm assuming you're
gonna get it in just just a few runs so
I'd say you come to the Titan production
facility go around kill all the trucks
you can save and quick come back to the
Titan production facility and just kill
torques again since that's there's the
best best net that can know you can also
farm
vending machines or try and craft it
however I do not think those either of
those will be nearly as fast as killing
the torque since you have a chance to
get a bunch of other Legendary's farming
vending machines however you might be
able to grind it quickly if you have to
high level Legendary's and a high level
grenade mod that has the same type
explosiveness
and spawning child grenades as the bonus
package so the rest of this video it was
just gonna be me killing things with a
bonus package I do hope you guys have
enjoyed this video I hope you stick
around on my channel since I'm going to
do be doing a lot more legendary guides
this and I have done a lot more a lot of
legendary guys before this so if you
want to see more legendary guides go
check out those videos you can see I do
have a pretty good array of legendary
guns that I'm using like this striker
you see right now I have a legendary
guide of my channel for it so I hope you
guys enjoyed this video I appreciate
that you've gotten all the way to the
end of this if you have since that's the
only way you'll be listening to me and
I'm I'm probably gonna sign now I'll let
the gameplay run and I hope you guys
enjoyed this and see you later god bless